[Music]
maybe an electrifying
dance or a quiet walk maybe study or
even having a power nap our bodies are
in constant need of energy every living
body is constantly working internally
our human body as well is extremely
dynamic and for this where do we derive
the necessary energy from we've usually
come across the same that we obtain
energy from the food we eat but that is
just partially correct
in fact the food we eat is just a source
of energy the energy is derived mainly
by the processes like the cellular
respiration which follows digestion
these two processes help in deriving the
necessary energy that is stored in the
food we eat in simple words the food we
eat contains energy stored in the
molecules in the form of bonds these
bonds are broken and the released energy
is converted into usable form also the
food we eat helps in providing the
molecules necessary to build up our body
tissues and for the efficient
functioning so how do all these
processes work what happens to the food
after we eat it where is it carried away
and where does it exactly get digested
how does the digestion process occur
exactly let's find answers to all these
questions in this and in the upcoming
videos to reach the answers we have to
travel the path of the complete
digestive system that's a very long one
so for our convenience we divide the
system into different parts the two
major components of the digestive system
that we will be studying include the
long pipe or the alimentary canal and
the digestive glands let's begin with
the first one
the alimentary canal is a long muscular
tube like structure which starts from
the mouth and ends at the anus the
a meter of this - varies from one part
to the other and what do we mean by this
can you tell me if the mouth stomach and
the intestines are continuous or there
are different parts that are just placed
one after the other
well the mouth the esophagus stomach
small intestine large intestine and the
anus are all in continuation it's
actually a single pipe that has varying
diameter at different locations and this
difference in the diameter gives us
these different organs so we can say
that the alimentary canal is a long
muscular tube that has various parts
like the mouth esophagus stomach small
and large intestines and the anus the
food is taken in by the mouth swallowed
and propelled further by the esophagus
the stomach takes up the charge of
maximum breakdown of the food and both
the intestines help in absorbing all the
stuff that is necessary from the
digested food but the process is not as
simple as it seems there is a lot that
gets into it let's have a look at each
part and its participation in the
process in detail we shall commence with
the mouth which is also called as the
buccal cavity now tell me one thing why
is the mouth included in the alimentary
canal why is it considered as a part of
the digestive system when its major
purpose is simply talking well let me
tell you an interesting fact our mouth
is involved directly in the process of
digestion rather it's the commencing
point of the digestion process yes the
mouth majorly is responsible for
ingestion that is the food intake
followed by both mechanical and chemical
digestion let's understand how there are
three major structures in our mouth that
aid in digestion they are the tongue
teeth and the saliva glands all of these
carry out efficient breakdown and mixing
of the food am
these we will have a look at the saliva
glands in detail when we have a look at
the digestive glands so we will learn
about the teeth and the tongue first
let's meet in the next video with
details on these topics
[Music]
you